so do we think differently okay-dokey
use a car Magruder sorry it's like a
tongue twister that's that's a boring
question the Whooper hypothesis as it's
known which is the idea that our
language affects our thinking has been
debated for decades even centuries
there's a growing amount of experimental
evidence that differences across
languages have an influence on the way
speakers of those languages conceive of
the world you can see that different
languages structure the world in
different ways they carve up the various
continued and different types of
relations in the world the weather
different languages chop up the world
almost can vary and that is actually
influenced how you see that world I
think language changes everything about
the way you think I go into a certain
mindset sound deeper than the way I
perceived situations differently I react
differently I think I'm more grounded
and more in touch with my emotions in
German yeah it makes me feel more
assertive when I'm speaking Dutch
because you kind of just get straight to
the point it's not just for talking
language is for organizing an otherwise
messy world into identifiable categories
it gives us ready labeled it's like Lego
you add another word to the word and
that makes it more precise language and
French is super gendered so everything
has a masculine or feminine and it just
makes everything feel a bit more one or
the other if you have a word like bridge
if it's in a language where it is
carrying a masculine gender then bridges
will be described by people slightly
differently so it might be its
usefulness or its power might be more
associated with the feminine gender
whereas its strength and its size might
be more sort of associated with the
masculine gender the structure of a
language forces us to attend to certain
aspects of a language that are certain
aspects of reality that are relevant for
a language at the moment of using that
lang
it's known as the thinking for speaking
hypothesis there's evidence that
language involves some kind of image
simulation and that has a consequence
for how we perceive of certain events
color is quite a complex property of our
visual world your brains decoding color
in quite a complicated way so you have
many languages that have a term to
denote both green and blue and typically
we'll call this a GRU term you find this
in languages like the Himba for example
in the Namibian Plains in this
experiment we ask participants to look
at the color tile and then after 30
seconds to show them the full array of
colors we say not pick the one that we
just saw and it's a very difficult task
if you're an English speaker but a human
speaker can do it like child's play
because the font color is central to
them you simply cannot recognize colors
that are not easily encoded in your
native language I think by virtue of
being born into a particular culture and
the language that goes with that culture
we are almost certainly given to think
in a particular way the human brain
doesn't work out of the box you grow up
and you're growing up learning languages
in particular environments so you've got
you know by the time you're dealing with
an adult you're dealing with a brain
that has been trained up to be an expert
along a number of quite specific
dimensions there's actually another very
very good reason to learning language
and that's simply to gain another
perspective on the world there you can
actually say a lot more a lot quicker in
aspects you can in English which is
quite interesting
it used to be nomadic which means the
language has to be a lot quicker because
you're speaking to people while moving
around and all this kind of stuff but in
a sense language is culture and culture
is language speaking a different
language is always kind of gateway into
a completely different culture
understand
we got her on or think Agartala kayo
droogies musica we do memorable when
summer she French in order as linguist
cognitive diversity I think is at the
core of human nature it is probably if
you're looking for universals I bet it
is probably the one true Universal of
humanity thanks for watching don't
forget to subscribe and click the bail
to receive notifications for new videos
see you again soon